this morning we have the first look
inside a new book that's expected to
have both Republicans and Democrats
talking the book is American carnage on
the front lines of the Republican Civil
War and the rise of President Trump it
features more than 300 interviews with
top Republican leaders of the past 20
years including President Trump and it
explores how a revolution in the GOP
propelled him to the White House author
Tim Alberta is political magazine's
chief political correspondent he's here
first on CBS this morning good morning
welcome good morning thank you for
having thanks very much for being here
you look at basically the current
political climate that created this
moment and what do you see as being at
the root of it well look I think that
there is a collective instinct for all
of us to to examine the national
landscape in this incredible amount of
polarization and disunity in the country
right now and lay it all at the at the
doorstep of President Trump and I think
that's a mistake because what I try to
explain in the book is that what you've
had swirling now for over a decade are
these forces of cultural displacement
and socio-economic dislocation an
enormous amount of of insecurity and
anxiety felt by a lot of Americans of
all political persuasions you write you
write his was a canopy of discontent
under which the grudging masses could
congregate to air their grievances about
a nation they no longer recognized and
the government they no longer trusted
that's right man that's good that's
pretty good yeah look I think it's
important to understand that that Donald
Trump was able to appeal to not just a
particular section of the traditional
Republican electorate he was in some
ways able to expand the Republican Party
in in reaching new voters but of course
in politics for every action there's an
opposite equal reaction and so while
bleeding some of the more
college-educated traditional suburbanite
Republicans he was able to still win an
election by appealing to a lot of
traditional downscale rural and exurban
Democrats who had never voted for
Republicans in many cases you know one
of the criticisms of President Trump is
not only that he's well this is a I
gotta go with this question here a lot
of people on the Democratic side but
also many Republicans are wondering
whether there are members of Congress
who are at some point going to challenge
the president not on his populist ideas
but on ideas that that many say are
nativist and racist in your reporting
did you find any member of Congress who
says you know what I'm almost there and
I'm gonna challenge him soon well a
couple of answers to that question first
to be a member of the modern Republican
Party today's Republican Party circa
2019 is to pledge undying allegiance to
Donald Trump or else right we have seen
that with the likes of Jeff Flake we've
seen it with Mark Sanford we've recently
seen it with Justin Amash who actually
left the Republican Party after calling
for the impeachment of President Trump
so you are very hard-pressed to find any
Republican on Capitol Hill who is going
to openly disavow the President or
challenged him in any significant way
that said when you get these folks
behind closed doors and especially if
you get a couple of Bud Lights into them
they'll tell you chapter and verse about
how much they dislike the president how
much they load the president the very
definition of cowardice to talk behind
closed doors but not take a stand
oh it's duplicitous but but that is what
the book tries to convey is that what
you are seeing on Fox News are what
you're hearing on local talk radio or
what you're hearing from some of these
members at a town hall back in their
districts is not what they actually feel
but they are sort of locked in this cage
of fear as it relates to the President
and they understand full well that if
political self-preservation is the name
of the game they cannot afford to cross
Donald Trump you're especially critical
vice-president pence writing that he
quotes so pitifully subjugated himself
that his friends wondered if President
Trump had blackmail on him a Republicans
not sold on Mike Pence as a successor to
Donald Trump oh I think that's an
understatement I think that Mike Pence
has wanted to be the president for a
very long time he left Congress went
home and ran for governor of Indiana
thinking that that would put him on an
eventual trajectory toward the White
House he was in very real risk of losing
his re-election as governor when Donald
Trump put him on the presidential ticket
that was sort of a lifeline but look the
vice president has been unflinchingly
loyal to Donald Trump and that is what
the president has expected from his vice
president but in so doing Mike Pence has
alienated some of his staunchest allies
in the Republican Party and I see it
very difficult for him to
have the seat at the table in the Oval
Office that he once hoped to have by
virtue of his service under Donald Trump
and he is just obviously one example
there are any number of Republicans
prominent high-ranking Republicans from
Paul Ryan Mitch McConnell on down people
who were once very critical of Donald
Trump and Mike Pence was one of them he
was a very very critical of Donald Trump
during the campaign privately and a
little bit publicly but when the time
came to either pledge allegiance or to
leave the party everyone made the same
decision and that's strictly because of
how they how they feel voters will cast
their vote come the next election
absolutely look you have an entire
Republican governing class who when they
saw Donald Trump's ascent they realized
that they had had it all wrong
that this message of you know whether it
was compassionate conservatism under
george w bush whether it was this notion
that free trade was was universally
beneficial to the american worker
you had a lot of republicans who
essentially took for granted that the
wall street journal's editorial board
was what the was what republican voters
used as their political bible and in
fact a lot of Republican voters and
voters writ large across the country
were in the middle of this sort of
populist reckoning this revolt that was
coming and not many people saw it Donald
Trump saw it very very early and so when
all of these other Republicans began to
realize just how forceful it was they
realized that they needed to either get
with him or get out of his way all right
Tim Alberta thank you for being here we
appreciate your insights the book
American carnage is out July 16th